these koalas are clinging on to life
desperately dehydrated with burnt paws
and it's a rush to treat them before
another fire front comes in so we don't
have any to the eyes around 25,000
koalas are thought to have died in the
bush fires on kangaroo island that's
half the population here dozens of
animals are being brought into the
Wildlife Center which set up an
emergency triage area can you see the
color of easier than water so he
actually can't see it also he's got no
no Menace response there and
unfortunately when when that happens
their prognosis is really poor because
they think they can't look out
themselves sometimes their vision never
comes back the decision is taken to
euthanize the wallaby for every one
animal that comes in here about a
hundred have died
Sam Mitchell's done this too many times
over the past few weeks trading down
there in the bucket sprawling the
tipping him in a hole words
the fires are creeping closer to the
Wildlife Center
so the Army's moved in its muscle to
clear as much of the tinder dry brush as
possible the center's inundated with
injured animals and as fast as they're
building pens for them to give them time
to recover more keep coming in even
though everyone here knows the center
lies in the path of the wall of fire but
Sam who owns the center is determined to
stay and protect his animals and the new
injured residents they're caring for
most of whom cannot easily be relocated
well defend the fires may well have
changed the island forever Sam's wife
Dana is now busy trying to feed and
build up some of the orphans left behind
and now living in their front room she's
drafted in her father and volunteers but
as well as the impact on Australia's
better known wildlife there are a grave
concerns that at least two other species
unique to Kangaroo Island may have been
wiped out because they're coming up my
grounds and this may have not had food
for a couple of days like a lot of the
adults coming in the second they come in
the first thing they want to do is a Bob
they're evacuating kondañña
yeah you guys have got to go to go
because remember they're going to close
the road
the winds are picking up but no one
knows exactly which way they'll blow
there are multiple fires forming an arc
around the Wildlife Center and closing
in one of the next-door farms is already
on fire and the smoke and flames are
gaining ground on the livestock I've got
a Joey dana decides she has to take the
couple's little boy out of the danger
zone to safety it's an emotional goodbye
some of the orphan animals are also
packed into the departing vehicles water
bombers and plane spotters fly overhead
constantly relaying the latest
information on the fire movement and it
doesn't look good as you can tell we are
gonna stay here and we're gonna try our
best to leave everything side there's no
guarantee we can do that so it's up to
you if you want to stay with us or if
you want to go if you want to go you
need to go right
we take their advice and head on out but
the fires have already crossed the last
road to safety with flames on either
side we leave behind the wildlife center
carers who have a frightening 12 hours
ahead of them and hundreds of animals
depending on them
Alex Crawford sky news on Kangaroo
Island Australia